The central player in the criminal
justice system is a prosecutor.
Uh,
prosecutors decide what cases are brought,
what charges are filed
against the accused,
what plea bargains are offered,
what sentences are imposed very often,
or at least have a,
a tremendous amount of
power in deciding that.
So today I want to talk
about the discretion that
prosecutors have and how it's
exercised,
uh,
and,
and how it has an impact,
particularly in capital cases.
Because as we'll see,
the two most important decisions in any
capital case is often made by just one
person.
Uh,
and that's the prosecutor,
uh,
called,
United States attorneys in the federal
system called State's attorneys or
district attorneys,
uh,
usually,
in the,
uh,
in the state system.
Uh,
prosecutors have all sorts of
discretion in terms of where cases go,
what cases are brought and so forth.
The first,
uh,
what to investigate,
how our,
uh,
resources,
law enforcement resources that
prosecutor's offices resources,
how are they going to be allocated?
Of course,
the prosecutor is always
going to be prosecuting.
All prosecutors offices are going
to be prosecuting violent crime,
murders and robberies.
And other,
uh,
crimes against people and crimes
where there's damage and so forth.
But there's a lot of discretion in terms
of how much emphasis might be put on a
economic crimes as opposed to our public
corruption or other areas like that.
Uh,
does the,
uh,
prosecutor look at financial,
business,
uh,
miss dealings?
It might be a basis for a prosecution.
Uh,
does the police send people
out to a restrooms to try
to find people looking for
sexual partners or do they try to find
people looking for prostitutes or do they
try to find people looking
to buy and sell drugs?
Uh,
and if they're looking for
people to buy and sell drugs too,
they dispatch those officers to college
campuses to look for a drug use there or
do they send them to
certain parts of town?
All of these things are going to influence
which cases come into the system.
Uh,
eventually.
and so,
uh,
the investigation,
is critical in terms of,
uh,
what kinds Chris in death penalty cases,
those cases are going to be
investigated and prosecuted,
but the overall power
prosecutors in that regard,
it is worth noting.
The next thing is whether
to charge a case or not.
Uh,
when,
uh,
some cases come into court,
let's say the quality of
life cases that you have in,
uh,
some cities now people are
arrested for loitering,
uh,
for small amounts of marijuana,
for,
uh,
jaywalking.
Uh,
are we going to bring charges?
Those people,
are we going to bring him before a
judge tried to get a sense or might the
prosecutor decline prosecution
in those situations?
And those can be a more
serious cases as well.
A person is arrested for assault.
Uh,
the question may be,
uh,
do they act in self defense?
Uh,
the prosecutor will study the case and
make a determination and perhaps decide
not to prosecute.
Uh,
the Strauss Kahn case,
uh,
where,
Strauss Kahn was charged with a rape,
sexual assault.
Uh,
but eventually,
uh,
the prosecutor's office in Manhattan,
a Dick decided to decline that
prosecution and not to go forward.
So this is a tremendous power,
uh,
that the prosecution has a,
in terms of,
uh,
whether to charge at all,
even though there may be a basis
for thinking there's a charge there.
Uh,
and then what to charge the same behavior
can often be prosecuted under a lot
of,
uh,
different,
statutes or laws.
Um,
assault,
uh,
maybe,
prosecuted,
for example,
is aggravated assault,
which might be a felony.
That is a crime punishable by over a year,
and it might carry 10 years saying,
just in some jurisdiction,
uh,
the prosecutor could charge that
same crime as simple assault,
a punishable by only one year.
So right there in making
that charging decision,
uh,
in charging the more serious
crime or the less serious crime,
the is deciding right there what the
range of punishments are going to be.
In one case,
it's going to be 10 years.
Uh,
in one case it's going to be,
uh,
just one year,
um,
uh,
in the readings we have that in Manhattan,
auto stripping,
uh,
it was charged as a felony.
Uh,
so it's more seriously
punishing Brooklyn's charge,
uh,
as a misdemeanor.
Uh,
so we have different prosecutors offices,
uh,
with different,
approaches to the same behavior,
uh,
but charging different things.
So again,
this is an area of
prosecutorial discretion,
um,
when to charge,
the,
uh,
case that will take up later in
the file name Harrison chronic.
Uh,
the government's been four and a half
years putting together this elaborate case
against him,
which involved a check hiding scheme.
Uh,
they've finally charged him with it,
a assigned a real estate
lawyer to represent it,
him to represent him,
and then told them to be
ready for Trump 25 days,
and they tried the case in 25 days.
Uh,
so obviously the prosecution,
if it does something like that
can get an enormous advantage,
uh,
in taking time to build a case.
Uh,
there's really no limit.
A lot of times when prosecutors
investigating cases,
one method they use as a grand jury,
that people can be subpoenaed
to go before the grand jury,
which is only the prosecution,
the witnesses,
there's no defense lawyer present there.
There's no judge present.
Uh,
and grand jury investigations
may go on for years,
uh,
before charges,
are,
are broad,
uh,
where to charge.
Uh,
this can be very important,
uh,
has been,
in drug cases,
whether those cases are charged in federal
court or whether they're charged in
state court,
most of those cases can
be charged in either one.
Uh,
particularly with regard to cocaine,
crack cocaine,
you can charge it state or federal court.
Same thing for powdered cocaine.
Uh,
and there was a lot of controversy
about where those charges were brought,
uh,
because they were often brought in the
jurisdiction that carried the heavier
sentence.
Uh,
we see that in death penalty cases.
for example,
if a potential capital
case is in Orleans parish,
say New Orleans,
Louisiana,
uh,
Orleans Parrish is about
70% African American.
So the jury is gonna reflect that there's
going to be a very large number of
African Americans probably
in the jury pool and,
and it will make it onto the jury.
Uh,
but if the case is
prosecuted in federal court,
it will be prosecuted in the
eastern district of Louisiana,
which includes not only Orleans parish,
but all the parishes around it.
In fact,
a very large part of the state
of Louisiana and the jury,
uh,
the percentage of African Americans
in that pool a is only 20%.
So by deciding where the case is brought,
the state's attorney and the United
States attorney can decide whether it's
going to be brought in a place where the
citizens are 70 per black citizens or
70% of the population,
or where the 20% of the population.
Uh,
the same thing happens in
Prince George's county,
Maryland.
These cases are often
brought in federal court,
uh,
in Maryland,
same thing,
uh,
around Saint Louis,
or in Saint Louis.
Uh,
those were not be the places where you
would think that would be the greatest
number,
a,
a federal death pony prosecutions.
Uh,
but it turns out,
uh,
that,
that it is.
Um,
and then,
uh,
as I said in state or federal court,
one other point to make is whether
they're brought in juvenile court or adult
court.
Uh,
used to be that any child,
anybody under 18 could only be prosecuted
in adult court if there was some
showing made by a judge I made before a
judge and a judge certified the case to
adult court.
Many jurisdictions today,
the prosecutor decides,
uh,
the,
children presumptively can be charged
as adults and the prosecutor can waive
prosecution and they're
prosecuted in juvenile court.
This is a classic example of how much
power has moved from the judges to the
prosecutors,
uh,
in terms of where cases are prosecuted
in terms of what sentencing a is
available for people.
Uh,
it's a,
it's a power that I think many people
may not realize is being exercised by
prosecutors,
uh,
in these cases.
Just to speak for a moment about the
investigation that prosecutors do,
which I've alluded to.
Uh,
obviously,
uh,
and let's talk about state prosecutors
because I said most of these cases are
going to be in the state courts.
95% of criminal cases are
state prosecutions and most
death penalty sentences
have been imposed in the,
in the state courts.
Uh,
but,
uh,
a state prosecutor,
a district attorney,
state's attorney will have,
uh,
all the law enforcement agencies,
the State Bureau of Investigation,
the local police departments
or sheriff's departments,
all of the law enforcement
agencies are available.
Of course,
that's what their job is,
is to go out and investigate crimes,
uh,
take statements from witnesses,
and so forth.
Um,
uh,
the states also have crime laboratories.
Now,
unfortunately,
a lot of the crime laboratories are
part of the law enforcement agencies,
uh,
National Academy of Science
and suggested that perhaps,
uh,
the integrity of some of the
science has been compromised to bed,
uh,
because it's not seen as science is as
much as it's seen as law enforcement
sometime.
But at any rate,
uh,
when the prosecutor
needs to have evidence,
analyzed fingerprints,
um,
uh,
you know,
DNA testing,
which of course is so critical today,
but all sorts of things,
uh,
the blood spatter analysis and so forth,
it has people on staff already,
uh,
to do those things.
And then of course,
prosecutors usually have a staff,
uh,
as well.
Uh,
worth mentioning is the
fact that a prosecutor has
a power that no other person
in the legal system has,
and that's the power to reward people
who cooperate and say what give them
favorable testimony for their
case and punish people who do not.
Uh,
we see this in cases where several
people are charged with a crime,
uh,
very often one will agree to
testify against the others,
uh,
in exchange for having the charges
dismissed or having to charges,
uh,
greatly reduced.
Uh,
but for example,
uh,
Sammy the Bull Gravano,
even though he committed 19 murders,
uh,
was allowed to plead guilty and get
only five years in exchange for his
testimony against Mafia boss John Gotti,
uh,
in the 1990s.
Uh,
that's the kind of reward that the
prosecution can give a witness,
a who cooperates.
Uh,
if the prosecution
doesn't get what it wants,
it can often make a life pretty difficult
for a person can investigate their
taxes.
And,
uh,
just about everything about them.
Uh,
when Webster Hubbell,
uh,
did not give testimony that the Ken
Starr Warning Against Bill Clinton,
uh,
star actually indicted
Webster Hubbel's wife,
uh,
as a way of bringing more pressure,
on,
on Webster Hubbel's.
So there's a tremendous amount of pressure
that often has brought upon people,
uh,
to,
to get them to cooperate if
some person is in custody,
uh,
where are they housed?
A,
are they housed in a part of the jail
where they're scared to death and
something could happen to them?
Or are they given some,
uh,
better,
arrangement in that,
or are they released pending trial?
Uh,
depending upon what their bargain
with the prosecutor may be.
Um,
and then,
um,
what penalty to see,
uh,
the prosecutor,
can influence,
uh,
the,
as we said earlier by
the charging decision,
uh,
if something is brought,
may carry a sends a 10 years,
then it's going to be a,
obviously a larger sense than if it's
charged as something that only carries one
year.
But in addition to that,
uh,
prosecutors can enhance senses
by a repeat offender papers.
It's just means the prosecutor files
of paper that says this person has two
prior convictions,
for example,
and if they're convicted of this,
it'll be the third time.
Three strikes you're out.
So they get a license instead of the
sentence that they would normally get for
that crime.
This can be huge.
Uh,
if the person is a charged for the crime,
that might only carry a
fairly small sentence.
Otherwise,
uh,
mandatory minimum sentences.
Most legislatures now have
passed mandatory minimum.
So for example,
if a prosecutor charges
someone with arm robbery,
uh,
in a state,
the person may have to
do at least 10 years,
uh,
before,
they're eligible for parole.
Uh,
the prosecutor can take that
away by just charging a robbery,
uh,
and taken away the arm robbery part of it.
And then the 10 years,
uh,
is no longer there.
This will be a subject
for plea bargaining,
which we'll talk about in a moment.
The one we're most concerned about,
uh,
the notice to seek the death penalty.
Um,
a prosecutor never is required to
seek the death polling in any state,
any jurisdiction in this country.
It's always a discretionary with the
prosecutor and some prosecutors don't ever
seek the death pony even
in states that have it.
And some prosecutors,
uh,
seek the death pony very frequently.
Uh,
but this is one of the two most important
decisions that are made in capital
cases because very often the prosecutor
won't decide or won't notice up the
death pony at all.
Uh,
and the case will never be
treated as a capital case.
Uh,
even though it may be a murder case,
and even though it may involve
a fairly aggravated murder,
uh,
that first decision when Robert Morgenthau
was the district attorney in New York
during the time that New York had
the death pony about 10 years,
uh,
he never sought the
death pony in any case.
Neither did Robert Johnson,
uh,
the prosecutor in the Bronx,
both of them had,
uh,
they just didn't feel like
the death penalty was,
was useful.
And so they did bring it.
On the other hand,
if you go to a place like Houston,
Texas,
uh,
prosecutors,
bring the death pony,
uh,
quite,
quite frequently.
Um,
and then finally,
the prosecution can also,
particularly in the federal system,
uh,
reduced the sentence again
for someone cooperating.
Uh,
they can note that the person provided
substantial assistance to the government,
uh,
and that can reduce,
the sentence that the person served.
So that's another incentive for
people to agree to cooperate with the
government.
Uh,
and then the most critical
prosecutorial decision,
what plea bargain offer or whether
to offer a plea bargain at all.
For example,
the defendant,
uh,
gives up his or her right to a trial.
Uh,
and in exchange for that,
the prosecution withdraws its
notice to seek the death penalty.
Uh,
that's the second most important
decision in every capital case.
And most capital cases will be
resolved with one of those decisions.
Either the prosecutor won't
seek the death pony at all,
or the prosecutor will
seek the death penalty,
but ultimately the case will be resolved
with a plea bargain and the defendant
will get sentenced usually to life
imprisonment without the possibility of
parole.
But sometime life imprisonment
with the possibility of parole.
And even in some cases a a term of years,
uh,
in the country today,
94% of all state convictions and 97%
of all federal convictions are guilty
pleas.
So as the Supreme Court has said,
uh,
this is a system of please
not a system of trials.
Most criminal cases from the most garden
variety misdemeanor shoplifting case to
the death penalty cases,
uh,
are going to be resolved
with plea bargaining.
Uh,
and so as I said,
these are the two most important,
uh,
decisions,
that are going to be made.
Uh,
and these are made in the complete
discretion of the prosecutor.
Uh,
often,
uh,
they're going to turn on the policies
and the politics and the attitude,
uh,
of the prosecutor,
the prosecutor,
uh,
mean some will decide to resolve a case
with a plea bargain and some will say
there's no plea bargain.
We're going to trial and we're
going to get the death pounding,
uh,
and uh,
or they may make an offer.
Uh,
the prosecutor may say,
uh,
we're willing to give you
life imprisonment or life
imprisonment without parole.
Uh,
but the defendant rejects the plate.
even though the prosecutor has decided
the case does not have to be a death
penalty case,
uh,
for the plea bargaining system to work,
the prosecutor has to go forward with
the threat and try and get the death.
Polly,
uh,
in the case,
just recently was looking at a case out
of Alabama in which the prosecutor had
offered the defendant eight to 10
years and the defendant didn't take it.
And so the prosecutor got the death poem,
uh,
as a result of the person's,
unwillingness to take a plea
bargain of eight to 10 years.
Obviously the death punny is a way in
which to pressure people to enter pleas of
guilty,
and it usually works.
Uh,
but as in that example,
when it doesn't work,
it results in a very harsh sentence,
uh,
for somebody who might
not have it otherwise.
No other country,
Aleks,
prosecutors,
uh,
that's unique to the United States.
This was an ad that Bob may see
ran when he was a long time,
a district attorney in Oklahoma City.
Uh,
he's running here on his record,
a 44 people sent to death row,
30,000 felons sent to prison,
uh,
15,000 juvenile gang crimes prosecuted,
and so forth.
Uh,
he'd returned $10 million of bogus
checks and fees to a innocent victims.
Uh,
so there are a lot of political,
uh,
as well as legal considerations.
Uh,
state prosecutors are elected
in judicial districts.
They're independent of each other.
Uh,
unlike in a European
system where there's a,
maybe an attorney general who then,
uh,
sets a policy for all
the local prosecutors.
Uh,
you can have prosecutors
right next door to each other,
uh,
in the United States who have completely
different policies with regard to all
sorts of things like auto stripping
and Manhattan and Brooklyn,
but also with regard to the death poly.
Uh,
so,
uh,
whether or not a person is in one county
or another may determine whether that's
going to be a death penalty case or not.
Uh,
for example,
there was a case and,
uh,
as unclear whether it
happened in Lexington,
uh,
county in South Carolina
or it was Columbia,
uh,
Lexington sends a lot
of people to death row.
Uh,
almost all white juries,
uh,
conservative,
Columbia,
uh,
very few,
almost no one sent to death row and
actually had to call in a surveyors to
determine which side of the
county line the crime happened on.
Uh,
and if it happened on one side,
it was almost definitely
going to be a death case.
And if it wasn't it,
it was on the other side of the line,
it would not be prosecuted.
Uh,
as a death penalty case,
uh,
we see this with individual prosecutors,
many him,
Garvis,
Davies and Illinois had
been sentenced to death.
It got reversed.
The prosecutor said when it came back
that he was not going to seek the death
Polly,
but then he went out of office in a new
prosecutor came in and he decided to
seek the death penalty and he
did seek it and obtained it.
So just the question of who's
in office as a prosecutor?
And when we see
prosecutor's offices change,
uh,
we often see great changes in their
policy with regard to the death penalty.
And so for example,
in Houston,
when Johnny Holmes and Chuck,
where the district attorneys,
uh,
so many people were
being sentenced to death,
that Houston is actually
executed more people,
over a hundred people,
uh,
at one time,
more than any state,
excel,
any state except Texas itself.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
in 2008,
judge Pat Lycos became the district
attorney and all of a sudden the number of
death sentences dropped
tremendously in Houston.
In fact,
now more death sentences
are imposed in Dallas,
uh,
then are imposed,
in,
in Houston.
But,
but what we see a lot of places is that
if a case is prosecuted in Houston,
at least during the Johnny Holmes and
Chuck Rosenthal era is probably going to
be a death case.
If that same case was
prosecuted in Dallas,
probably wouldn't be death case,
but at the same token of is
prosecuted in Philadelphia,
Lynn Abraham,
and she was the district attorney
there when for the death point,
virtually every case where,
where as possible.
But if the case was
prosecuted in Pittsburgh,
uh,
very little likelihood,
that the death penalty would be imposed
because of the prosecutor in that case.
So it just raises a
question which I leave,
uh,
for you to think about.
How important is consistency is the fact
that different prosecutors in different
parts of the state may have different
attitudes about the death pony,
different criteria for
seeking the death penalty.
Um,
is that something that's important or
do we leave that to the prosecutors in,
in each per a particular place?
And,
and do we,
by giving one person so much power,
uh,
is that subject to abuse,
isn't subject to race coming into play,
particularly when this decision is such
a subjective decision and is often made
by one person?
Well,
that's the issue that becomes a,
that we'll see raise later on.
Uh,
when we get to the question of,
uh,
racial discrimination and we
started seeing disparities,
uh,
and we say where,
who made these decisions?
These two most important decisions,
prosecutors are probably less accountable
than any other public officials in a
system where we have a lot
of checks and balances that,
uh,
limit a discretion of other,
actors,
uh,
in government,
that does not apply to prosecutors.
The judge cannot tell a prosecutor
you can't seek the death penalty.
In this case,
uh,
the judge cannot tell the prosecutor
to not to bring certain charges or,
or to make a certain plea offer if the
prosecutor decides in a death penalty
case that he or she wants the death
penalty and insists upon filing the notice
for it,
uh,
and pursuing it before a jury.
And if the jury returns
a capitol conviction,
uh,
and then makes the case to the jury,
if the jury imposes the death penalty,
then that's the penalty
that's going to be imposed.
The judge has no way really to
prevent that from happening.
Uh,
and we're so much power is exercised
a is in the plea bargaining process.
Uh,
there's virtually no way,
uh,
that an accused person can prevail
on a claim of selective prosecution.
There are often cases where it appears
that somebody is being prosecuted because
of their race or maybe because they
exercise their rights to free speech.
Uh,
and yet,
uh,
the supreme court has
said in a number of cases,
you can only prevail if you can show
that the prosecution was because of that
fact,
not merely in spite of it,
but you were charged.
Because of your race are you,
were,
you are sought the death penalty because
of your race or prosecuted because of
your exercise of your first
amendment rights to free speech.
Uh,
so what that really is meant is,
and the other thing is to
prove a prosecution claim,
a selective prosecution claim,
one almost has to have information that's
in the possession of the prosecutors.
And the courts have pretty
much said prosecutors,
uh,
do not have to give that information up.
Uh,
prosecutors have absolute immunity from
prosecution no matter what they do in a
case as long as it's in the
capacity of prosecuting the case.
Uh,
there are immune from being sued
for any misconduct that took place.
Uh,
John Thompson's case and,
uh,
out of Orleans parish,
Louisiana is a good example.
Uh,
Thompson came within weeks of being
executed even though there was a,
uh,
a lab report that showed that he could
not possibly have been the person who
committed the crime.
Uh,
it showed that the blood type was a
different type than Johnson's type,
the blood type of the perpetrator.
He brought a lawsuit.
He couldn't sue the prosecutors directly,
but he brought a lawsuit saying that
they hadn't been properly trained.
And then because the lack of training,
the parish of New Orleans and
the city were liable to him.
He won a $14 million verdict at trial,
which was upheld on appeal,
but then was reversed by the supreme
court in a case called chronic versus
Thompson,
uh,
which left him absolutely penniless in
terms of his recovery in that particular
case.
So prosecutors,
tremendous amount of power,
a tremendous amount of discretion,
uh,
and tremendous responsibilities
in these cases.
Uh,
very often the only investigation that's
going to be done in a criminal case is
going to be done by the law
enforcement and the prosecutor's.
It's just simply the defense is not going
to have the resources and the ability
to do it,
uh,
an investigation.
So prosecutors have a immense power,
uh,
and how they use it.
Uh,
we'll be seeing as we look at these cases,
uh,
that fall.